في اوكرانيا ايضا تتابعوا الجماهير
العريضه من عشاق كره القدم مباريات كاس
العالم بشغف في هذا المقهى الوحيد في
مدينه اوديسا الذي يعرض مباريات المونديال
جاء المشجعون لمتابعه هذه المسابقه
الكرويه التي يعتبرونها متنفسا ينسيهم
يوميات الحرب
الى الاصدقاء ونسيان الاشياء الفظيعه التي
تحدث يوميا من الجيد ان الروس ليسوا
موجودين في هذه البطوله روسيا ليست لديها
اي فرصه للمشاركه كما لم تكن موجوده في اي
مكان اخر
على غرار المدن الاوكرانيه الكبرى تعاني
مدينه اوديسا من انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
المتكرر غير ان عمال المقهى والزبائن
يتحسبون لاي طارق
لدينا مولد كهربائي كبير طالما ليس لدينا
نقص في النفط فلنواجه مشاكل في الكهرباء
في حال انقطاعتها الكهربائيه
كبيره هذا العام في اوكرانيا فان مباريات
الدوري المحلي لا تلعب سوى بالمناطق هي
الغربيه من البلاد ودون حضور الجمهور
وفيما لعب مجهزه بمخابئها امنه بعضها توقف
بسبب الغارات الجويه هذا بالاضافه الى ان
الحرب ارغمت فريق شختار دونيتك المرموق
على استقبال منافسين في دوري الابطال
الاوروبي في بولندا بدلا من اوكرانيا